the 2018 a.l cy young award winner 28
year old left-hander blake snell yeah
blake snell we last remember him in the
world series dominating these dodgers
and he's had an up and down start to his
year mookie betts digs in the next full
count pitch home to bets
and he got him and that's the slider but
see that's a pitch i would have thrown
right after an o2 now i know each
pitcher wants to set the tone and he
probably wanted to set the tone with his
fastball early on strikeout recorded for
snell is his first down of the night now
is the shortstop chris taylor and it's
hit well out to left field
that one will bound off the base of the
wall before fam can retrieve it and
chris taylor has a one out double in the
la half of the first runner in scoring
position now for justin turner who is
one of the best in the business at
taking care of those run-scoring
situations another fastball hit on the
ground sharply to cronenworth who
recovers to get the out on turner as
taylor advances to third so snell now
trying to strand a two out base runner
at third and he'll go to work on albert
and albert lays off ball four i mean
we're only in the top of the first
inning and this is a big spot for blake
snell already here's will smith the
catcher he homered yesterday 2-2
got him
rode the fastball upstairs to get out of
trouble a couple of strikeouts two
runners left stranded
it is the eight-time all-star three-time
cy young award winner clayton kershaw
making his 16th start of the year
tonight
misses down and in to fam and the padres
put their lead off hitter reward in the
bottom of the first
for whatever reason john leadoff hitters
have been a problem for kershaw's
fernando tatis junior now on the first
pitch he pops it wide to the back for
pujols and that's kershaw's first out
tonight you know this san diego team
they don't hit
well for average yet it can hit some
homers there's jake cronin worth now one
of the padres who does in fact boast a
high batting average chronoworth sends a
ball well head out to right field and
that one's gonna fly
and kershaw knew it as soon as
cronenworth swung the bat for jake
cronenworth his 10th homer of the year
four of those have come in his last
seven games here's manny machado now two
nothing san diego
that's the hole and that's that's what
makes kershaw so good and stubborn at
the same time you don't make that pitch
he's going to give up a lot more home
runs than he's used to giving up here's
will myers now
and myers picks on the first pitch a
chopper for turner
to finish the inning not before the
padres post runs first as eric hosmer
leads things off against kershaw in the
second
the padres are nine and one at home when
they face a left-handed starter this
year nice backhand to play by muncie
right off the il a fine play to start
the inning that's a great play and a
pick-me-up for
a pitcher when that ball's hit that hard
and there's really not a shift employed
and your second baseman covers that
ground clayton kershaw back to work they
put their feet up on the furniture
regularly in this ball park nobody more
so than kershaw 3-2 pitch to fam
and he gets him anyway
tatis as we mentioned when we went on
the air is playing in his 200th career
game tonight those two career home runs
against kershaw came on the same night
at dodger stadium this past april the
next 2-2 to tatis well head out to
center field
not deep enough to do any damage bets is
there to make the catch oh off the bat
it looked like he had one and kershaw
thought for a moment he might have had
one put traffic on base here in the
fourth so two on two out now for aj
pollock back to a fast ball it's hit on
the ground to machado long throw across
the diamond and
hosmer came off the bag
it looked like machado had made the play
but the throw brought hosmer off the bag
the bases are loaded now for steven
souza
and souza hits it on the ground to tatis
who'll go the short way to cut down
pollock and retire this side snell has
wiggled off a couple of hooks tonight
manny machado leads things off in the
padres half of the fourth oh wow kershaw
gets a call on a ball that looked like
it missed the corner of the plate and
that's three for kershaw tonight and he
can't handle that pitch right there
based on the style of hitting clayton
made the pitch there with two strikes
grisham pops it up
can of corn style for pollock this would
be a big one for snell to get the padres
deep into the game if only because he's
been so inconsistent of late third walk
by snell just a little bit of fire in
this conversation he's not going to
allow
snell to mess around here and let the
dodgers get back into it each
it seems like it's a game seven of the
world series type at bat for snell yeah
whether you know whether it's by his
grinding or just missing with command
it's deep everything goes deep and he
strikes him out snell saving his best
for last pitches around a walk in a
single two strikeouts clayton kershaw's
still out there on the other side of the
matchup pinch hitter is hasson kim big
curveball
which he hasn't seen probably in a while
i mean he was sitting dead
red oh another curveball and kim gets a
hold of one out to deep left and good
pinch hit homer on an 0-2 count
[Applause]
[Laughter]
we're being told has exited the game
with flu-like symptoms the dodgers have
loaded the bases with nobody out
and a game that has felt that has been
in the padres control the whole way not
so much right here will smith is the
battery
there's your double play ball machado
gets one himself throw to second doubles
off the pinch runner and there are two
gone that's a trade san diego will
gladly make taylor scores from third but
there are two gone
how about this for a spot to make your
major league debut jace tingler selects
right-hander mason thompson
and now the tying runs on base here's aj
pollock now pollock rolls over a ground
ball for machado and that'll do it the
dodgers settle with one in the eighth
they're going to turn things over to
their closer mark malanson in the midst
of a terrific year 3-2 to barnes out to
left field and well-hit and that one's
going to go it's a one-run game
the second pin [ __ ] homer of the ball
game and the tying runs the board with
two away
turner not known for going after the
first pitch but in the ninth inning i
think those
rules don't apply
out to right field myers drifting and
making a nice running catch to end the
night